43 años después que su vecina italia el
enclave de san marino república de
fuerte tradición católica aprobó la
legalización del aborto sanz marino
sigue el ejemplo de irlanda un país
igualmente conservador que legalizó la
interrupción del embarazo en 2018 sin
embargo tres países europeos siguen
prohibiendo la malta andorra y el
vaticano
otros dos micro estados lo limitan sólo
en casos de peligro mortal para la madre
o si se trata de una agresión sexual
mónaco y liechtenstein
pero los derechos reproductivos ya
conseguidos siguen siendo perseguidos
por los sectores políticos más
conservadores en otoño de 2020 una
decisión del tribunal constitucional
polaco controlado por los conservadores
del partido ley y justicia prohibió la
interrupción del embarazo en casos de
malformación del feto y sólo es
permitido cuando es producto de una
violación o si la vida de la madre corre
peligro más allá del continente europeo
está el caso de texas estado que tiene
duras restricciones a la interrupción
del embarazo la práctica es ahora
autorizada sólo antes de la sexta semana
de gestación momento en el que muchas
mujeres ni siquiera saben que están
embarazadas la única excepción es caso
de una urgencia médica la corte suprema
de eeuu con una mayoría conservadora no
se opuso a la ley por lo que muchos
defensores de los derechos de las
mujeres temen que otros estados sigan el
ejemplo tejano